i played the first four hours of
cyberpunk 2077 and i'm here to answer
that elusive question that many of you
have been wondering since e3 2018
how does cyberpunk 2077 play i have a
lot to talk about but before i begin we
have another video up right now that
details the story beats of the opening
hours and these main quests
make sure to check that out after you've
finished watching this
with that out of the way let's start at
the beginning
cyberpunk 2077 begins with an in-depth
character creator that lets you
customize your looks and appearance
but more importantly you are given seven
skill points to invest in five distinct
attributes that shape your play style
body reflex intelligence technical
ability
and of course cool each attribute has
skill trees attached to it and the more
you invest in a specific attribute the
more the associated skill trees expand
for example i put most of my points into
intelligence and technical ability
because i wanted to be a hacker
or to use the cyberpunk term a netrunner
this meant that right from the start i
had a good number of perks available in
the intelligence and technical ability
skill trees
as you level up you'll earn more
attribute points which can be used to
increase your base attributes and you'll
earn skill points which could be used to
unlock perks in skill trees
there are a ton of perks both passive
and active that could dramatically
affect or feed into your play style
these range from small buffs to brand
new abilities
for example i unlocked a hacking perk
that let me open lock doors
if i was able to successfully hack into
the local mainframe
unfortunately because i only got to play
the early hours of the game i didn't
have a chance to dig into the different
perks and abilities
however after a cursory glance through
all the skill trees i think that's safe
to say
that there will be plenty of options
thankfully v
is pretty malleable as well just because
i wanted to be a netrunner from the
start
didn't mean i couldn't level up and
invest in other skills and attributes
as i played i found myself more and more
reliant on stealth than i expected
most of the encounters would begin with
me hacking a character or the
environment
sneaking up on the distracted enemy and
either non-lethally choking them out or
violently snapping their neck
in almost every situation though i got
spotted and cleared out the remaining
enemies with my trusty pistol or a
grungy lead pipe i scavenged off a dead
gang member
so to recap each attribute is tied to
skill trees as you level up you'll get
attribute and perk points which can be
used to increase attributes and unlock
new perks respectively
you're not tied to a specific path or
playstyle but the attributes you invest
in will affect the perks you can unlock
in the early hours
like i said i more or less played as a
net runner a very bad net runner
and being a bad net runner meant that i
had to be ready with some iron just in
case things got hairy
usually i'd approach most situations by
hacking into an enemy this triggers a
hacking minigame that asks you to match
a sequence of numbers and letters on
your right with a bunch of letters and
numbers on your left
when you pick a number it locks you into
that row and you need to find the next
number or letter in the sequence
on that same row if you manage to find
that number or letter it will lock you
into the column and so on
it's a bit tough to explain but i
thought it was fun as hell could it be
gwent 2.0
i mean who knows what i can say is i
didn't think i'd be this excited to line
up numbers and hack stuff
once you are in the local mainframe you
can hack objects and characters in
different ways depending on your play
style
however you have to hack sparingly when
you first breach into the system
you are more or less given hacking
points everything you hack will eat into
those points
but of course my technical sleuthing
almost always ended with a
firefight complete with blood gore and
mayhem the myriad firearms i picked up
and messed around with were loud and
kicked like a donkey
this made gunfights feel weighty and
frantic as i ducked in and out of cover
based on the build i played the shooting
itself is serviceable
it's nowhere near as smooth as your
destinies or call of duties
but it was punchy and responsive when it
needed to be a generous aim assist pulls
your reticle to threats when you aim
down sights and headshots are rewarded
with a critical hit
indicator when i wasn't shooting enemies
i bashed them with a lead pipe the pipe
didn't quite have the same
thunderous impact that my firearms did
but it was fun charging threats and
thwacking them over the head whenever i
saw an opening
also deadly force isn't limited to
combat situations like in the witcher 3.
at the beginning of my demo i stabbed a
cop in a very gta fashion because i
wanted to see what would happen
night city pd promptly put out a warrant
for my arrest in the courtyard i was in
devolved into chaos
civvies were running around screaming
cars were honking and these hud was
constantly glitching in and out
i also hit some corporal guy with a pipe
because he told me to [ __ ] off
i regret nothing another big part of
cyberpunk's gameplay loop
are vehicles v owns a sporty quadrivitec
which they can call to their location
using the d-pad but you can also steal
parked cars with ease
stealing an npc controlled car though
requires a specific skill
as you'd expect cars handle differently
depending on their size
form factor and model these car felt
speedy and responsive making it easy to
weave between traffic and civilians
i also took a van for a test spin and
that felt sluggish and far less
responsive
as it should while vehicles were a
reliable way to get around the city i
actually found myself walking to most of
my objectives
the city is so dense and packed with
detail i was constantly getting
sidetracked the side alley would open up
into a bustling marketplace with food
vendors and shops
most of these areas were flanked with
colorful digital advertisements that
blared thumping music as i pushed my way
through the crowds
in one area i ran into a sidewalk
preacher yelling about how civilization
is doomed
after listening to his sermon for a bit
two young kish looking girls walked up
and started taking selfies with the
crazy street man
their words not mine the only reason i
didn't spend my entire demo aimlessly
wandering around night city was because
i had a time limit
now that i've gone over the gameplay
let's talk a bit about the quest in
cyberpunk
2077 like the witcher 3 there are many
different types of quests
all with recommended levels main quests
side quest gigs and incidental
activities that pop up on your map
if we use the witcher 3 as a base main
quest and side quest should be pretty
self-explanatory
gigs felt like they could be similar to
monster contracts and that they are
mostly self-contained stories that won't
affect the greater narrative in any big
ways
to be honest i actually didn't see too
many quests in my demo
most of the story quests i was able to
play we had already
seen however i did play a lot of these
incidental world events that reminded me
a lot of random encounters that you
might find in red dead redemption 2.
these usually consisted of clearing out
his own overrun by gangsters subduing
characters with warrants out on them and
looting caches
based on what i played these diversions
were pretty straightforward in theory
but
allowed for a lot of gameplay
experimentation with very little risk
in one section a gang had overrun a
small marketplace so
i hacked into the local mainframe
unfortunately i failed the hack and a
rival netrunner took notice
i think they set all my cybernetic
implants on fire but it was hard to tell
in the heat of the moment
all i know is that my screen turned
orange i couldn't heal and died
so i respawned and circled around the
marketplace to see if i could get them
from behind
i successfully hacked one gang member
and moved in slowly for some stealth
takedowns
but of course someone noticed me and a
lethal firefight broke out
while this specific instance may not
blow you away i'm really excited to see
how those combat encounters evolve and
develop as you build out your character
and unlock new skills and perks even
though i was early on i felt like the
game gave me plenty of options for
dealing with each encounter
so there's a look at the character
builder the combat the exploration
and the various events you will stumble
upon as you explore night city if you
enjoyed this video and want more
cyberpunk 2077 content we have our
impressions on the demo up now and a
brief story overview based on what we
know so far
and finally next week we will be doing a
q a video where we will answer your
questions about cyberpunk 2077
if you want to ask us something you can
leave us a comment below or you can find
me on twitter at jacob deck
see you next time you order
two tequila fashions with a splash of
service and a chili garnish
duo of johnny silverhands coming up
you